[Music]
in Alien updated news submitted by fire
festivals a storm area 51 event didn't
quite live up to the hype oh it happened
not a good response recap Maddy Roberts
you remember a couple months ago he set
up this Facebook event he was like storm
area 51 all his alien people were like
we're gonna do it and they had like a
million people that were like we're
gonna do it and then they got a bunch of
warnings from like the FBI and all kinds
of [ __ ] they're like dog doo yeah so you
can't arrest everyone is what the
ongoing thing that is what they shoot
you you know when it comes down to it
people get skirt oh yeah there ended up
being what they consider a positive turn
out the little the alien people they're
like you know what we like this turnout
it was about 300 people long yeah yeah
he went to the border of like where area
51 is and there was like tons of
policemen and tons of like armed guards
they were like if you step even one inch
onto this premise you will get arrested
or you could get shot at if you go any
further
oh they were like yeah we're good party
border and they had like bands playing
some vendors or like the vendors were
like yeah we don't believe in aliens but
like capitalism and they like we're
selling water bottle smart yeah they're
[ __ ] [ __ ] cuz they're like we're
gonna storm and if we storm in there's
nothing that government can do stop us
we demand this information
alien costumes back ah-choo we just
wanted to like you know hey ow what
happened to your manifesto that you
wrote where you're like the government
stop hiding [ __ ] yeah you know what I
think it is is like that's the internet
trolls that are like no [ __ ]
development blah and then the people
that actually show up or like the weird
alien hippie guy they really believe in
billing I wonder what's really happening
yeah dude this I'm saying like out of
those 300 people a hundred of them we're
just like people that know 200 or more
people like oh yeah it's meme and a
hundred of them or like I'm a [ __ ]
alien wait they're kind of [ __ ] alien
yeah I thought that was the whole point
really go inside and [ __ ] of alien like
I'm a [ __ ] alien oh no like [ __ ] me
I'm a fugly and [ __ ]
alien that was the whole point no you're
lying
wait how many people signed up for like
a million yeah like over a million
I feel like 999 thousand people were
just trolling
I was just a mean for them they weren't
really gonna go yeah and even the people
here they were like we weren't even sure
that it we were gonna storm it or not
but we thought it'd be a fun experience
and like we're here for the memories man
cool yeah because I would have gone to
watch them run forward and I would have
came in afterwards and been like wow
there's a lot of death here I mean out
of the 300 I'm okay how many would have
actually liked gosh I don't think they
would have got everybody yeah everybody
that's why it's not 300 like the movie
yeah 300 a movie they would yeah I have
to sacrifice a couple you know a few
bodies and then but I think it would
actually happen baby the town was on
high alert and so they actually did have
350 first responders standing the crowd
yeah just think I felt paranoid they
were yeah cuz they didn't know what to
expect how packed was the Denny's that
night probably pretty good
I'm exhausted and there is only one
business in the whole town Oh Lord
little I lay in and so that's where
everyone was kind of camping out is it
like a lien like a lien yeah
did you know they cleared out like a
whole lot so people could bring their
campers and hook up there like water and
power and stuff
I didn't yeah but it makes sense because
there's bands playing and stuff and they
only have like 8 rooms or something and
because no one ever stays there only
employees of the area 51 okay yeah yeah
so out of all 301 lady did get detained
for a brief second because she put her
foot over the line that you come here
you've like China put like do it Co do
it start with like your keys or a rock
who's like what if there's a dude that's
like this right in the minis right over
blast your toe off he goes maybe but
she's that cute girl face so like you
and they do that to you but they
wouldn't like she peels you're cops or
your fans to put the guns down like 250
with an alien you know I want to be in
the meeting with like you know with with
the police and all when they were
planning it out and like obviously they
were like let's have 350 first
responders but there was a plan being a
plan C oh I want to know what that was
like what do y'all think it could have
been me it's [ __ ] my gun
or that you know those stationary guns
but they're just real oh yeah the
Marines right one of those I shot one
before
just one boat during training yeah I
shot one in Vegas the machine gunner on
a Humvee that's you shoot one bullet
yeah they're expensive now is that way
just one bullet on those who know you
get to shoot it like it's raining but
that most of the training it's a
simulation so don't be like a Humvee
right like in this in this like big
internal building and there's screens
that go all the way around and it's so
you're in this thing and you're like
moving kind of like VR and then you get
to turn around and like blast fools are
on buildings and stuff okay I shot one
for 200 bucks so you save gas you paid
$200 tissue wood yeah I would say it's
called a minigun and it's like it spins
like this and then in and then it makes
your whole body vibrate like it's so
strong it's like it's not like ddddd
that's its old-school the new ones go
like that and it makes your whole body
go who's like that
yeah weird I want to try that I wasn't
scared because I like guns but it was a
crazy feeling where you feel it just go
all through your body like you're being
electrocuted me you doing that while
you're wearing a shirt saying I ain't no
[ __ ] that shops not up the job man
appreciate you writing that I know
biscuits or not question have you got
well I know I know y'all have yeah I
shot an m4 as I was called I hurt my ear
cuz I forgot to put earful
dangerous pretty bad why do you forget I
don't know I forgot told you yeah I was
because I was filming it for like this
promo thing and then like I got excited
and I forgot oh that's really on like my
ears were ringing for like half a day
Jesus yes death I know what yeah
dude I heard like a time where like like
Joe said Joe said I like guns and I was
like oh I had a period where I was like
yeah I'm tough I want to shoot a gun so
I paid all this money to take like a
shooting class or all time yeah well
guess what I went in shot yourself I
know that would've been fun I literally
shot one bullet and I was so upset I
cancelled out of the class I don't like
violence once it got way too real
through like Johnny and immediately was
like it was a pistol yeah their smallest
gun for me was like so big for my hand
and I don't have like the tiniest hands
you know like no definitely not but like
not the tiny no definitely not dude any
kind of gun I shot a Glock yeah right
yeah a Glock oh and then I and then I
shot a shotgun too but I oh my god that
would hurt my feet that would hurt my
shoulder I don't know if I could defend
myself like part of me is like that's so
badass and I wish I could do that but
then I think back to that time where I
had you know what's a water gun it was
it was like that big and I shot it and I
got dropped out of the class I keep my
money going it like [ __ ] yeah all right
teach me the right way ready boom I
don't like violence I'm out of this
that's exactly I was like I don't need
this I was like I'm gonna use my pan
it's just a tool it's like a drill or
like a staple gun or a fishing pole I'm
also terrified of stable a tool for
murder it's Gary's wall to put holes on
a piece of paper down far away it's a
it's a tool to get like glass bottles
and go
I don't know yes so anyway one guy did
get arrested because he urinated on the
premise cross it but he urinated on oh
that's funny so much - you get arrested
didn't do anything
yeah we're porta potties they're like
for the first responders in everyone
they did it doesn't say but yeah this
man was just I did see that headline it
was like area 51 storm Huntley's
underwhelming one arrested for public
urination few uh video but they're like
doing the news and there's people
running from behind the narrow road
homeless on yep
they have videos they have a lot of sex
those people hold it with each other
maybe or aliens for once I wish there
was boot police brutality to happen with
just batons and like tear gas had the
SWAT team down the street they should
have done that would be funnier be
hilarious out of all the groups I would
love to see that don't know what the
beanbags oil hat on and they're like I
knew this was gonna happen
the governor should have just [ __ ] with
them and did some actual like alien
staging [ __ ] like at night like that's
true they should have Frank them get one
person a just [ __ ] beam them up and
they're like no and then I go yeah I
wanted to go like oh alright I'm I'm
just gonna ask it and I'm sorry
conspiracy bows comes out every [ __ ]
time we film I just gotta say it why are
their being so protective of area 51 I
mean what is back there when they say
it's a military basement so they're
they're designing new aircrafts and you
can't have your enemies like knowing
your new technology have secret
technology because we have agreement
with the aliens and then the aliens give
us free technology
exchange we let them like but protrude
the cows I mean not just about the white
folk oh yeah and then the lonely white
people in the in the Midwest yeah yeah
they always get abducted yeah I don't
know why aliens don't get like our Ivy
Leaguers are the best of the best people
they for some reason always got to get
like the Juggalos but cuz I think
overalls come off faster Oh
[Music]